we're hearing from Mike Tobin there was
a revolver FONSI and he was shot by who
we believe to be a police officer we
have an adult black male and he's
clearly armed with a handgun police come
in a very short brief foot pursuit we
pulled the handgun or attempt to pull it
out there's a sound and a discharging
but police never discharged any weapons
we check him out we we finally stopped
him we get the weapon back
it is a revolver in that revolver there
are three cartridges one of them are
spent sounds to me like what's happened
is what's happened is we screwed up
Baltimore erupted in unrest on Monday
April 27th after the funeral of 25-year
old Freddie gray